Hello, my name is Philip Walton
I'm an engineer on the Chrome and web platform
team at footballing, and I'm really excited
to talk to you all today about this, because
container queries is one of my favourite topics
and a feature I've been waiting for for a
long, long time, and so I've a lot to say
about it.
Let's dive right in.
Container queries are a contentious topic,
and to fully understand why, you have to know
their history.
Like many things in this area, their history
starts with response to design.
So, in 2010, Responsive Web Design was published
and changed the way we think about web design
forever.
Web developers can build sites with one set
of styles and confidently serve those styles
to any device.
Over the next year or so, you started to see
the same questions popping up over and over
again: as the web matured and its modular
component-based architecture started to gain
popularity, a lot of people were noticing
the limitations of using media queries to
build responsive designs.
In 2013, prominent voices in the community,
like Nicholas Gallagher, were starting to
suggest that responsive designs should really
be component-based rather than viewport based.
Folks like Jonathan Neil started proposing
new syntax that could support element-based
queries in CSS.
Probably the most influential thing came in
April of 2013 a post on the front page of
Hacker News for a while.
He called - he said the definitions for the
design and lay-out of a particular site.
He said that what we really need are element
queries.
And this article is largely responsible for
popularising that term.
So, a few days after that, after getting slammed
with requests for this feature, my colleague
and CSS working group member, wrote a reply
that summarises the problems with element
queries, and it's kind of become the de facto
response from the working group whenever developers
ask for this feature.
So I will explain the argument in a second,
but for now, the main thing I want you to
understand, that in many of the valid points,
developers still wanted element queries to
be a thing.
Blog posts were written.
For example, this one includes a great example
that I think perfectly illustrates the problem.
So, with media queries, you can build a calendar
widget like this one and it works great on
desktop and mobile, but it only works if the
counter widget is rendered in the content
area that is the same width of the screen.
If you try to put it in a said bar, it will
break because the media queries report a wide
view port.
We need the ability for the calendar to detect
that it is in an arrow context and render
itself accordingly.
To prove that this is isn't a contrived example,
this is a an example of the new calendar in
Google and the same rendered in Gmail in the
side bar.
Not only is it being reused in a different
view, but being used in an entirely different
web application, two different code basis
using the same component.
This is a real-world example of how responsive
design is more than just about page layouts.
It is definitely about component layouts.
But since browsers weren't implementing element
queries natively, developers started to build
polyfils.
Since there is no official syntax, each made
up its own syntax, unofficial syntax.
The problem with inventing your own syntax
is that it creates a potential future compatible
risk.
Something we see a lot in the JavaScript community.
Recent examples like smush-gate chose to pinned.
It started a standardisation effort for element
queries.
And after their heroic work getting the picture
element standardised in browsers, developers
had high hopes.
Unfortunately, though, the work was met with
a lot of resistance from browser surrenders
as well as the CSS working group.
In 2015, an article was borrow and the challenges
and explained that element queries, at least
in the current form, were essentially dead.
Given the resistance and challenges related
to element queries, the group perspective
today for something they thought might be
easy to get through the standard bodies, so
they called it container queries, and thus
this new term was born.
Instead of having CSS conditionally target
an element itself, it targets the element's
immediate patient.
Unfortunately, while it's true that container
queries is less problematic than element queries,
they are still problematic and strong resistance
from browsers to implement them.
But was again, developers kept on asking.
It was hypothesised on Twitter, if element
queries were real, they would be used more
often than media queries.
So the question is: if container queries are
useful in design, and developers clearly want
them, why don't they exist?
It almost feels like there's this epic battle
between web developers and browser makers
where neither side fully understand the other.
Jimmy Keith describes the sentiment well in
a post he published a year ago in his blog:
according to him, browser makers always claim
they want real-world feedback from actual
developers, but when developers tell them
they want container queries, browser makers
don't know what to say."
To be honest, in my experience, this is mostly
true.
So you have browser-makers - so, I mean, it
begs the question: have browser-makers put
on their evil goatees, in a dystopian timeline
where developers don't get any say in the
future of the web?
Before we get too cynical, let's look at why
browser-makers are concerned about container
queries.
Due to the way CSS works in browsers today,
containers present two primary problems: the
first is the infinite loan incursion problem.
The second less familiar one is that they
actually break the cascade.
So consider these two CSS rules.
The first one defines an element that defaults
to 500 pixels wide; the second conditionally
overrides the first rule to say if it gets
wider, make it 4 pixels instead.
However, if we make it 499 pixels, then the
selector will no longer match.
But this means we are back to just the first
selector matching, and remember, the first
selector tells the browser to make the element
500 pixels wide.
That means the second selector now matches
again and you can see we have a problem where
an infinite loop and it's not an obvious way
to resolve this.
Note that this problem doesn't just apply
to element queries.
It also applies to container queries.
Oftentimes in CSS, an element size is determined
by the size of its children.
This is known as shrink-to-fit and it can
happen with things like inline-block and floats
like in this example.
So here we have a container floated and a
child element with a declared width of 500
pixels.
Since the container is floated, it will be
the same width as its child, so it is also
500 pixels wide.
But the next rule says in the event that the
container's width is 500 pixels or greater,
the child's width should be set to 499 pixels.
Since the container is floated, changing the
child's width will also change the container's
width to 499 pixels.
Now you can see that we have the same problem
that we had before.
So that's how container queries can lead to
infinite loops.
Let's look at how they brake assumptions that
the browsers make about the cascade.
In order to understand why this is the case,
you have to first have an understanding of
how browsers take CSS and HTML and render
content to the screen.
They render in three distinct phases: style,
layout, and paint.
Before I explain them, I wanted to make sure
one thing is clear: they are distinct and
sequential.
Meaning that each one must completely finish
before the next one starts.
That's very important.
Let's look at the style phase.
In the style phase, the browser goes through
every single element in the DOM, it matches
with with selectors in the CSS, and then it
determines what value should apply to every
single CSS property the browser supports.
This is known as the cascade.
Most websites have hundreds if not thousands
of style rules and DOM elements, so it's critically
important that this process can run as efficiently
and quickly as possible.
So I think most people in this room probably
understand how things like specificity and
short order work, so I will go through this
quick.
When doing style calculations, you have to
start with the root element in the tree and
traverse down.
Most of the time, s element is HTML, but in
this example, the root element is a section.
So the reason you have to start the root element
is because some properties are inherited which
means that you have to compute the full set
of properties for the parent before you can
move on to the child.
Actually, that's not quite true - technically,
you also need to list the default values for
every CSS property that's not mentioned by
any specific rule.
It looks like this which is just a little
bit verbose.
For the purposes of these examples, I will
imply this.
I will not list every single property that
the browser source in every single case.
Also, technically, you don't use the shorthand,
you use the longhand for these properties,
but this is getting into the details.
It's easy to show the individual properties
that match to the rules defined if the CSS.
So next to come to the UL, and we do the same
for it.
As you can see, there are four properties
and two rules, and the patient element doesn't
have any non-default inheritable properties
to those that apply, with , so this is the
full set of properties.
It gets more interesting when we get to the
LI.
As you can see, two rules match, but due to
source order, the second declaration overrides
the first one.
So this is the computed set of property.
We're not quite done yet because the LI is
a child of the UL, and that has a colour define,
and colour is inheritable, so you have to
add that to the list.
Anyway, sorry if this is getting too into
the weeds, but it is actually really easy
to see how this works when you look in were
your browser's developer tools.
All you have to do is select any DOM element
and look at the style paint and see the properties
that are calculated.
With regard to this pipeline, now we have
done style, only now with key do layout.
We do what is called kind of at least in Carol,
we call this calculating the box tree.
What you have - you have to take the full
set of cascaded properties for an element
and then you calculate all the kind of rectangular
co-ordinates of everything in the DOM.
In this case, we know that this element is
the root elements, so it starts out in the
top left at zero zero, and since we know it's
auto, we know it's going to fill up the entire
space, so let's imagine it's 600 pixels wide.
We don't know the height because we have to
go through all the tree, but we will get to
that next.
The UL is very similar.
It takes up the same space as the section.
But when you get to the LI, now we can start
developing this box tree, but the important
thing to remember here, and none of these
details are important, they're all kind of,
faking this example, but the critically important
thing to remember is we can't do layout unless
we know what all of the styles are, so we
have to do all the styles first, and then
layout.
We can't do them at the same time.
So the most ly boring part is over, but the
main part from all of that, is you have to
do style before layout.
Imagine now that we try to implement container
queries.
Imagine your browser, and you're going to
implement container queries in your browser
rendering engine.
So look at this HTML and CSS again.
Now let's add another rule that has a container
query.
So, as you can see, this rule conditionally
targets LI elements if the parent UL is wide
enough.
Let's try to compute what the cascaded property
values would be for the LI.
If you look closely, you notice that there
are two different values for the flex property.
So the question is: which one should be applied?
Well, the only way to answer this question
is to know how wide the UL is.
Is it wider than 500 pixels or not wider than
500 pixels?
Since we haven't done layout yet, we don't
have that information.
If you allow selectors to query based on layout
information, then you go from a sequential
rendering pipeline to something like this.
In this model, we do style again after layout,
but since doing style again might completely
change the results of the cascade, you also
have to do layout again, but doing layout
again may completely change what selectors
match which means you have to do style again,
and you have to repeat this process over and
over again until everything kind of settles
and there are no more changes and only then
can you move on.
This is much, much, much slower than what
we have currently today.
Given what I just showed you, I actually think
it's a good thing that browsers push back
and didn't implement container queries when
developers asked.
If they had done it how developers want it,
the web would be significantly slower today,
and nobody wants that.
There is good news: the reason I said this
isn't the darkest timeline because there are
few event in the history of container queries
that I skipped over and didn't mention.
The truth is that browser-makers have been
working hard to come up with performant solutions
to this problem.
In 2015, Chrome started implementing CSS containment,
giving developers the way to tell the browser
what parts of the page lay-out are independent
of the other parts.
It paves the way for potentially avoiding
the circularity issue, for example, with CSS
containment, you can specify an element size
can't be affected by any of its descendents,
no matter how big or small they might be.
Despite the appearance and belief by some
that browser makers and web developers are
at war, this is definitely not the case.
There are many examples of browser engineers
reaching out to developers and engaging with
them to see that the features they're specifying
will help solve real problems that the developers
are facing.
I know there are plenty of browser engineers
here today who would love to talk to all of
you, myself included.
So continuing on in 2016, Chrome started working
on a feature called ResizeObserver which is
one of my new favourite web APIs, letting
you monitor size element on a page with a
simple callback function.
Previously, you could only observe changes
to the entire window but obviously we know
it's possible for elements to change their
size, even if the window doesn't change.
Then, finally, in January of this year, Chrome
shipped ResizeObserver, which means the feature's
now available to over two billion users worldwide.
Where does that leave us today?
Some of these new features may seem cool.
We still don't have container queries, right?
If you squint your eyes hard enough, and you're
willing to take the definition of "container
queries" very annoyingly literally, then we
actually have had them since the beginning
of CSS.
For example, where here we define styles for
an input and header element and then override
the styles on the state classes that can be
applied to the state let me's containers.
A selector is essentially a query, right?
So these are kind of like container queries.
We can use the same concept to build something
today that I think is as good if not even
better than the queries that developers have
been asking for.
I call this responsive components.
Let me show you what I mean.
This is the CSS for component which uses the
hypothetical container query syntax.
You start by applying base styles to an element.
These styles apply, they define on the elements,
so they apply in all situations.
Then you additional styles for when the container
is 36ms or wider, and you add even more styles
for when it is 48 or wider.
This similar to how we do mobile-first design
today.
Now imagine you replace those hypothetical
pseudo-class functions with actual classes.
Of course, this isn't magic.
It only works if those classes are in the
DOM.
That's the only way that they will apply.
Then they have to be automatically added and
removed if the container changes size.
It will have to work a little bit like this.
Note how the classes are added and removed
from the container as the box gets bigger
and then smaller.
So the question is, can we make this work?
If so, how?
This is exactly where ResizeObserver comes
into play, and why it's is to so great.
This is code that implement the exact logic
I showed you in a previous slide.
It is not that much code.
Let's go through it.
The first thing you create is a ResizeObserver
instance and you pass a callback function.
This callback function is invoked any time
the elements that you're observing change
their size.
You get past a list of elements because elements
can change at one time and you're given more
details in those.
So, in the next function, we define a set
of breakpoint names and their respective minimum
widths.
This is the mapping between the break point
names we're going to use and the width that
we decide.
Then we loop through a list of break points
for each changed element, and then if the
element width is larger than the miniwidth
for the break point, we add the class element,
and, if smaller, we remove the class.
Next we set that the observer is now active
and monitoring this element.
This step is technically optional but useful
for styling the element in CSS if you want
to because it is often the case that you don't
want to show an element until its initial
break point is set.
Finally, we query for all container elements
in the DOM and start observing them.
I should point out that the callback gets
observed elements so you have to explicitly
observe them.
It doesn't by default observe all elements.
That would be too inefficient.
So some of you might share the opinion expressed
in this tweet, and while I understand the
sentiment, and, even though the technique
uses JavaScript, it doesn't depend on it.
It doesn't break without it, or if there are
any errors with the JavaScript.
So, if you look at the CSS again, you will
notice that I defined an initial set of base
styles that don't have any break point classes
attached.
If the user has JavaScript disabled or there
was an error when trying to run it, these
base styles will still apply.
It is like if you load a mobile website on
your desktop browser, it might look weird,
but it's still completely usable.
This is a textbook example of progressive
enhancement.
I don't see - even in cases where JavaScript
is disabled, or if there is an error running
it, we can use CSS to guarantee our components
will always be displayed because errors in
JavaScript will not affect CSS.
This is a great use case for CSS.
So, we define an animation with two-second
initial delay that fades in for each container
element, and then if the JavaScript fails
for some reason, the cache element will still
become vis - the container element will become
visible at most two seconds after the CSS
is loaded.
When you're ResizeObserver code runs, and
it runs sooner than that, we remove the animation,
and so everything works as normal.
Lastly, we add a no script tag, so if JavaScript
is turned off entirely, we show the element
no matter what.
We don't have that delay.
So, if you're building a complex web application
that has container queries, there's a good
chance you're using a component architecture,
whether it is something like React, or native
web components, you can get to dynamic DOM.
With custom elements, you can hook into the
custom callback which gets invoked when the
element is added to the DOM and observe new
container elements as they're created.
As a point, you don't have to worry about
unobserving removed elements because that
gets handled by garbage collection.
The other really nice thing about using custom
elements is then you can give them more meaningful
famous like this.
You can also easily define a base container
class that all other responsive components
can extend or behaviours that they can mix
in.
I know it's not cool to show a slide with
minified code, even though this is a - 100
per cent of the code to make this work, both
the CSS and the JavaScript, is on this slide
right here.
And this is actually hand transpiled ES5,
so it will work in IE11 as well.
Also, note, this assumes that the browser
supports ResizeObserver, so, if you want to
use this code on a producer that doesn't use
ResizeObserver, you can import a polyfill.
You don't have to load the polyfill, because
if the browser doesn't support ResizeObserver
and you get an error, you get the base styles.
So, to prove that this technique works, I
built the demo side a few days ago showing
the - you can resize them in a variety of
different ways, and the UI is supposed to
mimic common patterns that I see in the wild.
So, in this case, the side bars are expandible
and collapsable, and this pane is resizable
by the user.
There's no way to handle situations like this
with media queries, because you have no idea
what the user's preference will be and what
size they will make these errors.
It is built with regular DOM and as well as
custom elements, and the source code is clearly
linked from the site so you can dive in and
see how it's implemented.
The site works cross-browser.
It is not a Chrome- onlithing.
It even works in IE and even works when JavaScript
is turned off.
Even though ResizeObserver is chrome-only,
this demo shows that that is not a good enough
reason not to use the technique.
It does work everywhere.
It is progressive enhancement like I said
before.
So summarise, container queries don't exist
in the form that developers have been asking
for.
There are lots of ways to mimic the behaviours
with web technologies.
The strict I've outlined here is performant,
it is easy to implement, it doesn't require
any specific JavaScript framework or build
tool, and even works without JavaScript entirely.
Now that we've discussed the past and present,
let's look at what the future might bring.
So the good news is that the W3C, through
their web community group, has restarted the
container query efforts.
This has been led by Mozilla and the new spec
is being edited by Tommy Hodgkins, the creator
of the polyfill before while it's impossible
to say for sure what the future will bring,
let me give you a couple of my predictions:
first, browsers are definitely not going to
be making the web slower.
This means that any future container solution
will be built on top of exiting optimisations
like CSS containment and ResizeObserver.
Second, I think web opponents and APIs will
be a big part of this future.
I imagine we ship something like a declarative
resize element or component that requires
60 CSS containment, that way, browsers can
easily optimise for it.
If you're not familiar with web APIs.
Talk to me about it afterwards.
It is a really exiting new idea.
I think some of the experimentation that browsers
are doing with async layout might lead to
breakthroughs in the efficiency we can do
layout, even if that happens, I don't think
container queries will be implemented if they
require a multi-pass rendering.
You can imagine if layouts becomes ten times
faster this the browsers pip don't think the
browser will lose the entire 17 gain to introduce
a slow feature.
Normally, they will be shouting from the rooftops
how much faster their browser is than the
competition.
Final thoughts: first of all, ResizeObserver
finally gives you see the ability to build
ultra performant truly responsive components,
so please build out the ATI.
If you find anything cool, share it.
CSS containment will likely shape the future
of container queries.
If you haven't used it, you should try that
out as well.
It can make your site feel faster.third, browser
makers and weapon environments should not
feel like they're at war with each other.
They should be working together.
But don't forget, that, while browser makers
want the to please web developers, their ultimate
responsibility it to the users, and that's
what we as web developers should care most
about as well.
Let's make the web faster for everybody.
Thank you.
[Applause].
Here are the links I talked about.
I will be at JS CSSconf as well if you want
to talk about these things.
[Applause]